Guten Morgen Tim.
Stör mich nicht ich versuche die Daten Elche anzulocken.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 262 live aus der Diaspora.
Ich muss ja wir haben so wenig Netz dass wir gerade noch versucht haben den Balzruf der Elche aus dem internet herauszuholen aber das Internet war alles alle Pforten zum letzten sind uns verschlossen und deswegen habe ich gerade einfach mir vorgestellt
wie der Balzruf der Elche klingt der also weiß ich nicht.
Ob der Daten ist glaube der Balzruf der Daten Elche klingt bestimmt anders.
Jahwe der Balzruf der Daten Elche ist ebenso.
Blöd die älteren unter euch erinnern sich.
Die Eltern unter euch erinnern sich ja das war noch.
Wir hatten wenigstens ne.
Da war es ja der ja okay also so schön war die alten Zeit noch ehrlich gesagt nicht also da war noch einiges zu,
was hatte es hatte zumindest mehr akustische Romantik heute hat man einfach nur kein Netz und damals wusste man wenigstens wenn man Akustikkoppler rein hustet dann gibt's halt Datenfehler ja die Daten Elche die haben auf jeden Fall Echo,
erzeugt wir haben wunderschöne visuelles Feedback bekommen von von Max genau.
Max und zwar der uns drei gleich drei Daten Elche gezeichnet mit dass es mit das ist hiermit wie heißt das mit Kohle das oder so ne das gezeichnet oder am iPad.
Ich würde sagen mit.
Ich würde sagen das ist mit Kohle.
Möchte Bleistift zum weichen Bleistift dann kannst du also mit dem Finger irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Also von jemanden der es kann Dreiecke mit Mobilfunkgeräten und Daten Erich Antennen auf dem Kopf in der nähe eines GSM Masten sich Endhaltestelle.
LTE wir hoffen das LTE ist.
Sieht halt aus wie geht es Emma und die freuen sich und es sind die da an Elche Alkis data access heiße.
Altes da tlmp.
Als es da tlmp.
So will ich das jetzt mal aussprechen wenn auch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher wie so lateinischer Tier Varianten ausgesprochen werden aber sehr schön gemacht,
Daten echt mit Nacktheit Mobilfunkantenne in der Mitte und die das große Beweise natürlich dann für die WLAN Verteilung zusteht.
Weil ich habe ja kein Latein gehabt aber ich sage das ist icos data lnp.
Wir werden korrigiert W.
Wir werden korrigiert werden sie haben auf jeden Fall zwei falsche Antworten gegeben und sie will wissen wer eine Antwort im Internet sucht,
darf nicht fragen sondern muss einfach eine falsche Antwort geben insofern wissen wir wir werden korrigiert werden sowohl was den Balzruf oder heißt das brunftruf oder sowas.
Grund Dich sind ist man und balzende so dass Herr bei also dass du bist schwierig von der Ruf aber ich weiß ja nicht ob es überhaupt rumbeißen wir lassen das mal den vier Kindern.
Die kleine hier herkommen.
Bevor bevor wir da.
Die kommen aus dem Nichts.
Bevor wir dafür noch kritisiert werden erwähnen wir auch noch das Datum ist handelt sich nämlich dabei um den 20 Juli 2018 genau und wir sind gerade in der Diaspora da wo das.
Wir sind 60 km außerhalb von Berlin.
Sich nee soweit ist es noch nicht mal.
Aber Auto wenn man über die Autobahn fährt schon mit dem Fahrrad fährt wie ich denn zur viert.
Na ja wir sind bestenfalls 5 km von der Ringautobahn um Berlin herum entfernt und das.
Also quasi am Arsch der Heide wir haben halt einfach kein Netz.
Verfasse gelesen Girl so ist er nicht gesagt nicht so weiter.
Ja berichte mal die Antenne danach aus ich habe dir das gesagt.
Der gibt der ist nett.
Ich habe immer noch Hoffnung dass die Daten ich hier vorbeikommen und retten.
Ja ich habe auch noch Hoffnung.
Aber hier merkt man wirklich und damit diesmal ja im Prinzip dann auch schon an das Thema der letzten Sendung an also da wo wir jetzt hier uns gerade befinden,
man einfach wie schlimm es ist ne also es ist es ist es wirklich in
beide zu bedienen ja ich meine man könnte ja über kleßen-görne immer noch sagen naja das wäre so Naturschutzpark und wenn man schon kein Licht anmachen darf damit man noch die Sterne sehen kann dann
hat mir ja schon mit elektromagnetischen Wellen aber,
das ist ja auch ein Dauerzustand und es ist einfach so lächerlich was was hier an Infrastruktur angeboten wird und jetzt und da sind wir dann vielleicht auch gleich bei unserem ersten Thema,
jetzt haben wir mal geschaut und festgestellt
das demnächst ja mal wieder nichts Versteigerung angesagt ist nicht also
die älteren mal wieder unter euch dürfen sich noch erinnern wie das so beim letzten Mal gelaufen ist da gab es ja die Versteigerung also die beim vorletzten Mal ich erinnere mich an vorletztes Mal an die UMTS Versteigerung.
3 GB 3G Versteigerung Wadi.
Genau ich glaube den Witz habe ich schon mal gebracht das war er von unserem damaligen Finanzminister Hans Eichel der irgendwie dazu befragt wurde weil die ist ja sauber für die Bundesregierung gut gelaufen da sind xx-treme Beträge erzielt worden.
4G war nicht mehr so viel ne 4GB 60 Milliarden ich glaube aber LTE varimi über 100 oder so.
Ich bin nicht zahlen fest auf jeden Fall waren damals alle extrem überrascht darüber das überhaupt unternehmen mit dafür soviel bieten würden also da waren die Unternehmen Dauer der Öffentlichkeit schon so weit voraus und dann gabs ja diesen kleinen Witz von Hans Eichel der meinte UMTS das steht für,
unerwartete Mehreinnahmen zur Tilgung von Staatsschulden.
Mehr haben wir damit auch nicht angefangen mit der Technologie.
Nee das ist das war's dann auch so und jetzt ist.
Wir müssen jetzt vielleicht etwas erklären also ein Staat übt eine oder starten üben üblicherweise eine Hoheit aus über,
den Luftraum in dem Sinne dass sie sich erlauben die Frequenzen und die Sendeleistungen,
zu regulieren und sagen wir auf diesem diesen Band was was ich da gibt's jetzt hier CB-Funk citizen broadcast Das gibt's glaube ich so gut wie weltweit
das ist dann standardisiert und dann wird gesagt wir sagen auf diesen Frequenzen diese dieses Frequenzband ist jetzt reserviert für diese Anwendung und die
die unterschiedlichen wenn man jetzt also einen Funk,
Gerät also nicht nur ein Funkgerät auf 30 du willst ein Funkmikrofon herstellen da musst du eben wissen in welchem Band du das machst dann gibt's bestimmte Bänder die sind eben
freigegeben für WLAN
2,4 Gigahertz und irgendwann 5 Gigahertz Bereich diese Frequenzen sind dann eben mal der der der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung gestellt unter bestimmten Regularien darf Sohn zu starke senden und so weiter.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt man möchte in LTE Funknetz bauen dann braucht man da natürlich auch,
mehr oder weniger deutschlandweit diese Erlaubnis auf bestimmten Frequenzen die dafür geeignet und standardisiert sind zu funken,
und dass diese dieser wird die Frequenzbereiche sind eben mehr oder weniger definiert durch den Standard selber,
und dann durch das was die Geräte unterstützen was sie also von was sie finden Baseband drin.
Wobei man zwei Dinge unterscheiden muss das eine ist halt dass es dem Staat
opin steht diese Frequenzbereiche zu regulieren das ist ja eine sehr gute Sache weil gelbe ist das nicht dann der wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig nutzbar jeder würde irgendwo lang Funken via da sie möchte und das
Ergebnis ist dann halt ein Drama weil damit wird eben für alle nix nur.
Durch diese Regulierung wird ebenfall hindert das so dass das eine das andere stört ne das jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich die Kameras sind auf der Frequenz und der Langstrecken Funk von ihr welche Flugzeugen ist auf einer anderen und dann wird halt geguckt das
das ist halbwegs sortiert.
Genauso das nichts funktioniert Radio nicht irgendwie Polizeifunk nicht eigentlich gar nichts ist ja auch sinnvoll und teilweise ist das nationale Regelung teilweises ist EU teilweise ist auch international normiert
im Mobilfunkbereich ist er der Frequenz Hunger relativ groß am Anfang gab es da noch,
Ich will dich gerade nicht glaube am Anfang waren zwei für die USA schon mal generell woanders unter.
Soja die sind genau das.
Europa und im Prinzip hat sich das jetzt erst mit LTE,
wirklich so ein bisschen aufeinander eingeschossen aber auch mehr dadurch dass man gesagt hat wen nehmen jetzt mal alles was noch irgendwo zu holen ist schmeißen das mit rein das ganze läuft dann eben in so verschiedenen Bändern und da darf dann,
das dürfen die geredet weil sie nutzen was sie können wann hat das ja gesehen in letzten Jahren,
habe jetzt den Mobilfunkgeräte jede Smartphone was auf Markt kam hatte dann wieder noch ein LTE Band und noch ein LTE Baden noch ein LTE Band die Zeiten wo früher ein Dienst auf einen Frequenzbereich mehr oder weniger fest,
ich war die sind so ein bisschen vorbei es geht halt jetzt,
es ist halt jetzt technisch möglich und so wirds eben auch gemacht dass die Geräte mehr oder weniger alles unterstützen können weil sie in der Lage sind über diese Antennen durch die Digitaltechnik sich im Prinzip auf alles ein zu tun und deswegen wird es an der Hinsicht auch ein bisschen entspannter.
Dennoch muss ein Mobilfunkunternehmen wenn es sagte möchte ich hier so ein Netz betreiben sich dafür die rechte die quasi die,
nicht exklusiv aber die überhaupt die rechte holen deutschlandweit ein Netz in einem bestimmten Frequenzbereich zu betreiben mitbestimmt Sendeleistung nach Standard hast du nicht gesehen und da hat sich eben die Bundesrepublik Deutschland bei,
3G zumindest ich weiß nicht wie es bei GSM war ob sie auch versteigert wurden oder damals.
Na da wurden die Lizenzen noch generell vergeben weil er gab es ja im Prinzip von Anfang an nur zwei Bewerber also das war ja damals,
die Telekom genau und Mannesmann die haben dann die D-Netze gemacht das waren halt die 900m Netze und dann gab es die,
E-Netze das war der 1800 Bereich das war dann E-Plus und.
Und danach vier Kinder.
Genau heute o2 mittlerweile sind die beide ja auch in einem und diese ersten E-Plus und o2 Geräte quasi konnten halt auch nur 1800 der Frequenzen und Telekom hat an der Soße,
alles Vergangenheit so läuft jetzt halt nicht mehr jetzt muss man sich aber generell eben fragen ist eigentlich dieser Vergabe Modus,
wirklich so erfolgreich gewesen und es ist die einzige Art und Weise wie man es machen kann die Realität ist jetzt wir haben,
die nächste Technologie steht vor der Tür das ist einerseits die Anpassung oder Erweiterung des LTE Technikraum spricht man von 4,5,
LTE ASU 4,5 g,
das passiert quasi auf weiteren Erweiterungen Frequenzzuteilung was ich genau wie ich das jetzt nicht erläutern soll von LTE und daneben 5g die eben.
Weil sie die Infrastruktur der Zukunft ist auf dem extrem hohe,
Geschwindigkeiten erzielt werden sollen insbesondere dadurch dass die Zellen auch sehr klein werden,
Porno geht das dann wirklich so im Monat 203mm Bereich also dass man eben so eine Stadt Bahne Ballungsräume werden
extrem kleine Sektoren unterteilt weil geringer Abstand zu Sendestationen erlaubt eben hohe Datenraten,
dann braucht man halt sehr viel von diesen Zellen aber die sind dann eben in der 5g Technik auch sehr viel billiger,
zu machen allein schon deshalb aber so viele davon braucht es also einfach nur ganz anderer ganz andere Marktdynamik die an der Stelle kommt nichtsdestotrotz haben wir dann halt immer noch so diese Logik na ja wir brauchen jetzt
Wettbewerber die Wettbewerber sollen alle ihre eigenen Netze nebeneinander aufbauen und damit die sich halt nicht in die Quere kommen kommen müssen halt in den gültigen
Frequenzbändern dann die einzelnen Slices dann den einzelnen complete Idiot Uhren zugeteilt werden
anstatt dass man halt vielleicht ein anderen Satz Ansatz pflegen würde wie z.b. wann kommt ihr auch sagen naja.
Alle Frequenzen können überall verwendet werden und alle teilen sich das und die eine Dienstleistung beginnt erst dahinter das mal so einem Meer mehr so eine Ente
Kupplung von was man sich als Netzwerkinfrastruktur vorstellt und was der einzige die eigentliche Dienstleistungen dahinter ist angeht.
In Deutschland ist sie also,
der während hat ehrlich jetzt gerade über die Versteigerung das ist das was im bei 3G und 4G gemacht wurde mindestens bei 2G weiß ich es einfach nicht,
gestern als sagt wer darf hier Funken und die Situation zumindest in bei 3G und 4G war mehr oder weniger dass die,
Bundesrepublik Deutschland Bundesnetzagentur gesagt hat Bier,
verkaufen quasi diese Lizenz meistbietend an die Meistbietende Instanz und dann sind natürlich die wird die Mobilfunknetzbetreiber hingekommen haben gesagt wir bieten soundsoviel
für was weiß ich das Recht in verschiedenen Frequenzbändern hier in LTE Funk zu betreiben.
Und bei der,
bei der UMTS Versteigerung ist voll war das wurden insgesamt 60 Milliarden eingenommen,
die also die deutschen Mobilfunkanbieter,
an die Bundesnetzagentur an den Staat gezahlt haben damit sie diese Netze betreiben dürfen da hatten die aber noch kein,
aber die hatten alle 60 Milliarden ging erstmal den Staat dafür dass es machen
und dann mussten die diese Netze bauen dann kommt der nächste fang in der nächste catch twenty two die mussten das getrennt voneinander tun die durften ihre Ressourcen nicht bündeln sondern mussten,
in einen und müssen auch heute noch in einen Konkurrenzkampf treten,
diese Netze zu betreiben es war glaube ich eine Ausnahme irgendwie das Fiat Intercom damals also das was heute oder Tourist,
als sie angefangen haben haben die glaube ich teilweise Roaming in die anderen nationalen Netze gemacht weil die hatten einfach noch kein Netz das wurde irgendwie mit einer Ausnahmegenehmigung erlaubt aber.
Es ist,
aber die machen es ohnehin nicht die Netzanbieter aber es wäre nach meiner Kenntnis auch nicht ohne weiteres möglich dass jetzt z.b. die Deutsche Telekom und Vodafone sagen wir bündeln einfach unsere Kapazitäten ihr baut in kleßen-görne wir waren dafür in
Nauen und dann dunroamin unsere,
Kunden bei euch und umgekehrt das ist in Deutschland zumindest für den dauerhaften Betrieb nicht gewünscht,
weil dann wären die ja ein Kartell das ist also die die Argumentation kann ich schon verstehen weil dann hätten die,
würden sich auf einmal zwei Marktteilnehmer eben diese Infrastruktur Teilen hätten quasi würden einen Kartell bilden hätten automatisch durch ihre Bündelung die marktbeherrschende Stellung und das sollen die nicht die sollen bitteschön so weil die Idee,
zum Wohle der Kundinnen und Kunden in Konkurrenz treten damit die um die Wette Netze bauen.
Weil wir ja wissen Wettbewerb bisher immer gut.
Grundsätzlich wäre natürlich gut gewesen wenn er an der richtigen Stelle gewesen wäre jetzt haben die natürlich schon dir in der Situation dass sie ihren,
ihre Netze.
War in Konkurrenz Bauern aber natürlich auch in unter ökonomischen zwangen die irgendwie günstig zu bauen und dann kamen solche Situationen widi widi wenne letzten Sendung gesprochen haben dass sie sagen ey weißt du was,
nach kleßen-görne bauen wir unseren jetzt nicht das lohnt sich nämlich nicht da brauchen wir lieber noch noch eine Antenne irgendwie,
in den Berliner S-Bahnring außerhalb des S-Bahn Rings lohnt sich auch schon nicht mehr wie wir gerade erfahren.
So und jetzt ist unsere Frage ist das denn so sinnvoll die Unternehmen so stark zu belasten wenn die hier die Infrastruktur bauen wollen die werden ja eigentlich vorne und hinten nur gestreift.
Ja und es gibt ja auch Gegenbeispiele also in Schweden gab es diese Versteigerung der Frequenzen nicht,
sondern da ist halt gesagt worden ok wir würden euch jetzt hier nicht auf von vorne rein so viel Geld auszugeben
nur für für die Frequenzen sondern ihr steckt das mal schön alles in den Netzausbau denn wir wollen auch überall Netz haben,
und in Deutschland war das halt nicht so in Deutschland wurde daneben blumig gesagt 98%.
99 wurde gesagt glaube ich oder oder wart aber 98 die Vorgabe.
Ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau.
Aber so irgendwie nicht.
Sind wir bei 98 und auch wenn es nur 99 sind ich mein ein Prozent der Bevölkerung ist immer noch eine ganze Menge Leute einerseits und es ist halt eben,
der Haushalte also nicht der Fläche und deswegen habe ich das Problem ich wohn zwar jetzt hier nicht auf dem Acker aber ich bin hier
genau deswegen will ich ja Mobilfunk haben
aber da ja hier keiner wohnt und so ein bisschen absurd dass man ausgerechnet Mobilfunk danach bemisst wo Leute wohnen weil es ja Mobilfunk,
soll ja eben dann funktionieren wenn man mobil ist hat ja auch lange genug gedauert bis zur Autobahn und wir sehen ja die Situation noch an den Zügen ist es ja heute noch dasselbe Drama ja das wär also einfach die Hauptverkehrsadern
da wo Leute langfahren und da wo sie wirklich angewiesen wären oder wo sie einen höheren Bedarf haben Annette genau dort eben diesen nicht erhalten.
Und die 98% jetzt die Deutsche Telekom z.b. abdeckt der Haushalte,
oder der Bevölkerung übersetzen in 82% der Fläche und das erklärt natürlich dass ihr jedes fünfte Mal wenn ihr aufs Handy gucken.
Welcher so ist das ne.
So und jetzt haben sie sich ja auf dem mobilfunk Gipfel den wir letzte Mal schon erwähnt hatten zu dessen Feierlichkeiten dann auch in in kleßen-görne,
unter traditioneller.
Festakt Stimmung der Diesel zwei Mobilfunkmasten in in Betrieb genommen wurden,
in diesem Mobilfunk Gipfel haben Sie sich jetzt geeinigt ja also.
Wir könnten jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen ausbauen und das machen wir auch,
und da wären jetzt irgendwie tausend Funklöcher geschlossen und du fragst dich ernsthaft achso es ist gibt noch tausend,
ja also die die Zahlen das sind natür das sind beeindruckende Zahlen wo sie sagen will von denen sie sagen dass sie die jetzt erreichen werden aber der Skandal ist eben dass sie das unter anderem,
auch durch diese hohen Gebühren natürlich die Unternehmen dich in der Lage waren also dass die die operieren tatsächlich unter natürlich,
ökonomischen zwangen und Sohn Tim Höttges kann auch nicht hingehen und sagen ich baue jetzt mal irgendwo so eine völlig unrentable Funkzellen oder 1000 Stück davon,
weil der sich eben auch dafür rechtfertigen muss der der macht das ja auch nicht weil da weil er irgendwie böswillig wäre oder sagt,
ich bin zufrieden wenn ich 82% der Fläche Deutschlands mit dem besten Netz das zu bauen ich anstrebe.
Audi musste halt riesige Milliarden Kredite aufnehmen und bezahlen und das sind halt einfach,
die irgendwo wieder reinkommen also ich will jetzt nicht komplett aus ihrer Verpflichtung daher raus haben aber es ist jetzt eben auch nicht nur so dass die Telekom schuld ist,
man kann ich schon feststellen dass ist halt alles insgesamt Versagen des politischen Systems an man hat einfach,
getöteten falsch gesetzt man hat nicht das richtige Modell gewählt dass es funktioniert noch kann man einfach jetzt mal sagen Hansi,
wann gings los Anfang der 90er Jahre das ist jetzt alles bald 30 Jahre her und,
klar haben wir da auch Fortschritte gemacht aber wenn man sich eben anschaut
thurneysen bisschen leid in Schweden Vergleich reinzuziehen aber die marschieren da halt einfach mal ganz anders voran und die haben mit
ihrem Einsatz ist einfach geschafft dass da einfach überall Netz ist und das auch noch schnell und billig so uns auch nicht nur Schweden das ist auch Finnland,
ja wo ist das hat mir das hier noch als separaten. Eigentlich irgendwo in unsere Notizen aber das war ja so eine Mail und die ist auch noch letzte Woche so ein bisschen über den Ticker gegen er hat Finnland,
Fertig mittlerweile mehr Daten über Mobilfunk als über Festnetz an.
Also die der durchschnittliche Mobile Daten Verbrauch in Finnland übersteigt den durchschnittlichen lendlein Datenverbrauch in Deutschland also das was ihr.
Auch in Deutschland.
In Deutschland ja Vollkatastrophe,
Vollkatastrophe also ganz ganz peinlich ne also irgendwie sowas wie wie im wie Vorrundenaus bei der WM könnte man fast sagen der soll das jetzt Ihr wie hier.
Da mein PC lief.
Um um für dich das auch ein bisschen greifbar zu machen.
Ja also der die durchschnittliche das durchschnittliche finnische Handy ballert mehr durchs Mobilfunknetz als ihr mit euren kompletten Haushalten durch die Kupferkabel.
Mit eurem BitTorrent-Client und YouTube und alles.
Aber um kurz sie also dass diese 60 Milliarden bei den 3G Lizenzen waren natürlich unglaublich hoher Betrag,
ich lese für die LTE Lizenzen wurde sehr sehr viel weniger ausgegeben da fahren wir 4,4 Milliarden aber trotzdem Geld was halt irgendwoher kommen musste und das ist irgendwie nicht nicht so sinnvoll ne,
zumal eben diese Verpflichtung oder die Erlaubnis nicht zu Vollabdeckung und so das sind natürlich echt schwierige,
schwierige Zugeständnisse na weil wenn man dann da eh wie die Prozente eben falsch besetzt und sagt okay,
der Haushalte Stadt der Fläche dann.
Genau an dieses Kooperationsverbot was es da halt auch gibt es macht es einfach auch komplett unmöglich da eine Verbesserung herzustellen.
Wenn du sagst sie sollen wirklich nett zu gegeneinander bauen dann dann musst du natürlich auch sagen die dürfen nicht kooperieren die Frage wäre.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht wo das Problem sein soll was man wo ist denn das Problem wenn einer sagt ich bau den Süden stärker aus oder ich mache mir da ich mache mir da.
Der Grund die Überlegung wäre eben dass sie dass sie dann einen dritten Marktteilnehmer.
Nachteile stellen konnten und,
und dass du wenn sich das große katell aus den drei Mobilfunkanbietern entscheidet dass ihr eines net
nicht in deine brandenburgische Pampa gebaut wird dass du keinen Konkurrenten hast der dir ein alter dieses Angebot machen soll das ist die Argumentation dahinter die ist natürlich unsinnig,
weil wir letztendlich der daneben mehrfach Netze mit Betrieb mit Aufbau und den ganzen Investitionen das heißt wir leisten uns in Deutschland ja im Prinzip im Moment dreieinhalb Mobilfunknetze ein Teil von dem was,
Telefonica von E-Plus gekauft hat wird er auch wieder zurückgebaut.
Weil die eben gerade in Metropolen sagen ja nee brauchen wir also nicht aber das Handy jetzt quasi wenn der Infrastrukturausbau aus einer Hand kommt,
dass du dann eben keinen hast der sagt ich brauche den noch mal woanders hin wenn du jetzt wenn sich die eben entscheiden gegen dich dann gibt's keine soso die graue Theorie dann gibt's keinen Konkurrenten der sagt okay dann brauche ich das halt aber da das ohnehin nicht lukrativ ist,
tritt ihm auch dieser Fall nicht ein ne also das was sie verhindern wollen wollten nämlich Funklöcher passiert,
trotzdem weil sie,
weil sie die Mobilfunknetze neben die hohen Kosten auf gebildet haben und die Mobilfunknetze eben sagen wir sind nicht gezwungen da was hin zu bauen wenn sich das für uns nicht lohnt wenn er keine keine schwarze Null hinter ist Herr Schäuble verstehen sie doch das für dich machen.
Genau und wann musst du das nicht auch wirklich sagen wir brauchen einfach 99,99 prozentige Abdeckung der Fläche so
dass er noch ein bisschen mit mir diskutieren wenn da irgendwelche schwer zu erreichende Naturschutzgebiete irgendwo in der Mitte wo sowieso kein Mensch Langlaufen soll da ist das da mal so ein bisschen.
Wetter Malente.
Das ama.at ist gut ne aber der Anspruch muss halt bestehen und im Prinzip hätten auch schon seit 10-15 Jahren schöne kleine Autos von der Bundesnetzagentur durch die Gegend fahren müssen,
ja, überall mal gucken was was denn so zu erzählen ist,
und alte Daten gibt es ja nicht da kann sie jetzt hier mit diesem ganzen Apps wo dann die Leute die Funklöcher melden können oder man so ganz überrascht dass es dann tatsächlich auch noch welche gab also bitte das.
Ich bin jetzt also in Bonn oder.
Ja da da da fehlt auch einfach die Kreativität und das Verständnis für das Problem und das ist halt so ein Bereich indem,
einfach dieses Land furchtbar abgehängt wird und es ist.
Tja also jetzt werden Anfang 20 19 sollen dann in Mainz die Frequenzen für 5g versteigert werden im November soll entschieden werden wie dieser Modus stattfindet.
Und jetzt ändert sich die Hoffnung dass man dieses Modell wie man es bisher.
Gemacht hat irgendwie überdenkt Ja und sagt wir machen es jetzt mal so das Ziel der,
Regulierung ist dass wir so ein Netz haben und nicht dass das irgendwie die die Unternehmen da falsche Anreize.
Genau und dazu muss auch einfach so ein Roaming einfach gehen das im Interesse der der Verbraucher ich sehe überhaupt nicht ein warum ich jetzt weil ich Kunde bei o2 bin und die mir meine Daten geben warum ich dienen nicht auch mal aus einem Telekom Mast rausziehen kann.
Ja also zumindest in in in kritischen Bereichen also man.
Das wäre die ich ich denke das sinnvoller Modell also ein Wettbewerbsvorteil des Modell wäre das,
tatsächlich ein Netz eben in den Händen des Staates ist,
und der Stadt im Stadt zu sagen einmal 60 Milliarden oder wie viel auch immer dafür dass ihr so Funken dürft sonst wäre halt zusammen ok wir bauen dieses Netz für decken damit alles ab und dann vermieten wir das,
die Ressourcen dieses Netze ist mit Gewinnpotential an.
Mobile network operator send Mobile virtual network operator ist also quasi zu sagen so du willst nur WiFi Netz betreiben ja klar kein Thema Stöpsel deine Faser bei uns irgendwie in Frankfurt und wo noch alles dran
sieh zu dass du dir die Jedi die Ressourcen von uns mietest von der.
Deutschen mobilen netzbetreibergesellschaft und dann kannst du ihm die Metaebene mobil machen hier mit Flatrate für alle,
oder Daten Elch unlimited.
Also es muss natürlich schon kompetitiv sein im Bereich von von Diensten ne also nur nett anbieten
so das eine aber du hast ja in zunehmendem Maße Features unserem Netz die sollen halt auch kommen man muss halt einfach diese physikalische Ebene der des Erreichens und der der der Nutzung der Frequenzen
trennen von dem eigentlichen Angebot was dahinter was ist was halt in zunehmendem Maße einfach bedeutet du kriegst schnelles Netz so und wenn ich an derselben Zelle und wie aus einem Telekom Vertrag mehr Speed raushole als mit dem o2 Vertrag,
dann.
Dann wartest du 24 Monate und versuchst du kündigen.
Nächster Halt klixer Halt und hast 24 Stunden später und wieder einen neuen Vertrag so
also auch diese Laufzeiten von 2 Jahren sind ein mega Hemnes und ein Riesenproblem hätte man das ganze mal auf ein halbes Jahr maximal begrenzt oder sowas dann wäre da auch viel mehr Dynamik drin und sie sind ganz Innovationszyklen werden dadurch natürlich auch.
Das ist das ist wirklich das ist sehr sehr eine Faulheit begünstigende Regulierung.
Wollen wir nicht wir wollen schnellste internetanbieter Frühschwangerschaft.
Der Punkt dürfte langsam rübergekommen sein.
Wir versuchen diesen kurz sein damit du die noch hochgeladen kriegen bekommen zu wissen Thema.
Wir bleiben quasi bei den Kartellen,
google hat eine Kartellstrafe bekommen und zwar die bisher höchste Kartellstrafe die jemals verliehen wurde lesen wir uns war 4,43 Milliarden Euro von der EU.
Und zwar das ist auch echt die bis dato höchste Kartellstrafe hat doch Microsoft dafür bekommen dass sie den Internet Explorer als.
Nee nee google ist schon auch selber auf Platz zwei Jahres gehabt schon anderen Fall.
Wie viel wie viel musst du denn Microsoft damals zahlen.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau war google war mit dem anderen Fall auch wir auch schon rüber um die zwei Milliarden also das ist definitiv.
Idee die Idee einer Kartellstrafe ist also man bekommt eine Kartellstrafe wenn man eine,
nach erinner Markt besetzt marktbeherrschende Stellung hat und diese ausnutzt zur,
Minderung des Wettbewerbs und bekannter Fall eben aus dem All Zielbereich Microsoft hat sein Betriebssystem rausgeschickt mit einem vorinstallierten Browser der hieß damals noch Internet Explorer,
und sie haben es quasi sie haben den wirklich bevorzugt ja so wenn man einen anderen Browser installieren wollte und jetzt zum Standard werden wollte ein ging das nicht ohne weiteres und so,
heute heute aus heutiger Perspektive ein Klacks aber großes Thema haben sie eine Kartellstrafe zu bekommen weil sie ihre marktbeherrschende Stellung als Betriebssystem,
Bereitstellen des Unternehmen genutzt haben zum Nachteil,
ihrer Konkurrenten auf dem Browser Markt insbesondere in dem Fall Mozilla die mit Netscape Navigator oder also hieß er noch nichts gibt damals ich weiß gar nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht mehr das war so wo sich das gerade geändert hat.
Netscape Navigator und Firefox oder was auch immer hatten eben Nachteile so,
sehr ähnlich kriegt jetzt Google einen auf den auf die Strafbank und zwar weil Google.
Das Betriebssystem Android welches ja eigentlich ein Open-Source System ist,
verwendet hat um die Dominanz der Suchmaschine zu zementieren und seinen,
Konkurrenten die Chance Chance verwehrt hat eine Innovation zu ermöglichen ja und zwar.
Kaufen Android Handy hast du,
diese ganze Google Geschichte dann auch hinten dran hängen hast du den den Chrome oder was auch immer dann vorinstalliert du hast Google Play,
Google Maps und sonstigen Kram einfach da drauf ne es gibt,
muss natürlich auch lobend erwähnen Distributionen von Android die wo Menschen mit viel Mühe versuchen den Google fangen wieder auf Android raus zu schälen wie heißt das jetzt noch mal das hieß immer.
F-droid oder was.
Nee erfreut ist der der libre Markt als ein alternativer App Store in dem alles nach nach den ordentlichen,
Open Source Lizenzen ist und Google frei so und wie ist denn diese dass sie es früher als Jano Jin Mod und jetzt heißt das.
So es gibt es gibt für die für die Liebhaber und lieferbar waren so eine selber zu installierende,
Android Version die daneben von Google befreit ist aber wenn du jetzt als Betriebs als als als Mobiltelefonhersteller Saso ich möchte aber jetzt hier so ein Handy verkaufen und da soll irgendwie Android drauf
dann sag Google eben naja pass auf folgende Bedingungen sind einzuhalten wenn du.
Mit uns hier zusammenarbeiten möchte und wir möchten bitte und und es ist sehr viel günstiger für dich wenn unsere Apps vorinstalliert sind und solche Scherze und genau diese
Taktik die eben zur Bevorzugung von Google-Diensten welche ja Internet Dienste sind geführt hat rückt,
all die Europäische Kommission und sagt 4,43 Milliarde Euro Strafe.
Und innerhalb von 90 Tagen ist Schluss mit diesen illegalen Taktiken.
Und die Standardsuchmaschine auf euren Android-Geräten und welcher Browser auf einen Nr Geräten Android-Geräten ist darf nicht mehr so sein sonst,
gibt es weitere Geldstrafen in wie 5% des täglichen weltweiten Umsatzes oder sowas ne pro Tag.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss dass es jetzt noch nicht rechtsgültig das kann jetzt noch angefochten werden.
Muss aber sofort quasi bezahlt werden also nicht nicht überwiesen Google.
Geld muss hinterlegt werden genau.
Eine Bankgarantie geben aber das Geld nur ist jetzt erstmal eingefroren Google ich gehe davon aus dass Google einen Einspruch vom Gericht der Europäischen Union einlegen wird um dagegen vorzugehen.
Samsoe schon angekündigt.
Und bis dahin muss das Geld dann eben,
auf auf ihr also ihr wo eingefroren sein jetzt muss man natürlich sagen dass das Google jetzt ohnehin nicht so ein großes Problem ist wir reden hier von 4,43 Milliarden,
google hat letztes Jahr 110 Milliarden Dollar also Imbiss 94 Milliarden Euro.
Gewonnen also ja umgesetzt und.
Der Gewinn war.
Also bei 60 glaube ich ne.
Ja das ist ja so schon,
ist aber jetzt auch nicht unerheblich sie mögen diese Kohle haben aber shareholder finde das halt gar nicht so lustig und von daher muss man mal schauen wie man muss auch sagen,
bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich so ohne weiteres mit dieser Entscheidung mitgehe,
ich kenne den Fall jetzt auch nicht besonders gut deswegen ist es etwas schwierig weil der Argumentation von Google ist Hertha türlich auch so naja will,
ohne Unterzieher sozusagen das auch gar nicht erst gegeben,
also weil wir geben euch ja auch was kostenlos dazu wären wir ja nicht verpflichtet gewesen und Apple z.b. gibt ja gar nichts weg und ermöglicht diesen Markt gar nicht erst,
das ist ja quasi Google sieht das glaube ich so ein bisschen wie ihr eigener Betriebssystem Markt wo eben andere auch sehr frei,
versandfertig zu Apple also wo es gar keine Lizensierung gibt es da natürlich schon sehr viel Wert mehr Varietät möglich na die Hersteller können quasi selber entscheiden was da drauf ist,
der Unterschied eben dieser Google Sache anfangs war ja auch sehr viel mehr im Betriebssystem drin dann haben sie das irgendwie alles ausgelagert auch deshalb um,
Updates besser zu ermöglichen weiß natürlich dann auch von der Update Strategie der Hersteller der anderen Telefone abhängig waren und Security Fehler nicht.
Sind sie jetzt gerade sehr die die Zügel an also das da ist Google gerade dabei und dadurch also dadurch dass das so liberal war und vergeben wurde die Lizenzen oder die rechte Google Betriebssysteme,
in dieser Form zu nutzen,
ist Google gerade sehr bemüht dafür zu sorgen dass auch diese Standards eingehalten werden ja weil letztendlich gerade werden jetzt verwendet die Puristen protestieren aber,
in das durchschnittliche Android-Handy ist einfach nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand so dass wird auf auf dem billow Geräten,
installiert und von denen gibt es viele und dann gibt's da einfach auf kurze Perspektive keine Updates mehr weil das eben irgendwelche,
ja billig Geräte sind wohl jetzt nicht im im Verkaufspreis noch eine Preis war das da noch lange eine Nachsorge betrieben wird oder so das mag immerhin das mag alles sein dass ihr mit mit irgendwelchen.
Mods und so weiter ganz tolle Geräte betreibt so ganz cool f-droid tolles Ding auf jeden Fall ist auch unglaublich wichtig diese Arbeit aber,
in der Breite der Bevölkerung gibt es einfach nicht,
aktuelle Android Phones die halt irgendwo beim Discounter an der Kasse lagen für den Preis wo man sich wundert dass dafür überhaupt das Gerät gebaut werden konnte und daneben das da irgendeiner noch sich Mühe gibt und da Updates für macht oder sind es einfach nicht der Fall.
Tja und da da da kümmert sich Google jetzt drum dass sie eben auch in ihre Bedingung zu denen eben auch gehört wir wollen ja den Chrome drauf haben und wir wollen da Google pay und den unseren AppStore Pipapo drin haben,
gehört eben auch dass sie jetzt sagen so und wir wollen dass das auf dem aktuellen Patch Level gehalten wird so jetzt haben wir natürlich aber auch,
immerhin ein Argument was man nicht verschweigen darf dass sie sagen wir möchten dass unser Apps oder drauf ist weil wenn sie sagen.
Unser Apps auf diesem Gerät,
dann haben sie die Kontrolle darüber und der vertraut das Gerät ja auch erstmal nur diesen App-Store also mittels Code signing heißt Zertifikate werden genutzt wie bei Apple um zu sagen diese App darf auf diesem Gerät ausgeführt werden.
Sehr wichtiger Schritt zum Schutz vor Schadsoftware,
und natürlich auch ein sehr wichtiger Schritt zum zum Schutz des der finanziellen Interessen eines App-Stores jasoosi können einerseits sagen na ja wir wollen Sie im Interesse unserer Kunden sicherstellen dass Software aus vertrauenswürdigen Quellen.
Geprüft und so weiter ist.
Die da drauf installiert wird weil unser Ruf leidet wenn die Leute auf einmal aus dem Ho-Chi-Minh Flowerpower Enterprise App Store ihr wie finfisher runtergeladen haben die haben also auch immer Argumente für ihren für ihren,
geschlossenen Kram und man muss zumindest aus einer,
qualitätssichern im Perspektive in der Breite sagen dass da natürlich dieses Apple Modell was sehr viel Receiver ist.
Dann doch besser funktioniert hat was jetzt die Qualitätssicherung angeht.
Aktuelle alle Geräte auf dem aktuellen Stand halten also apple veröffentlicht sind ja dann immer so solche Sachen wie so wir haben iOS hastenichtgesehen ausgerollt neue Version nach einem Monat irgendwie,
über 80% der Geräte auf.
Na ganz so schnell geht's nicht aber.
Bei ihm also so.
Nach dem Jahre alt wird dich den Großteil in die Zukunft geholt und das ist.
Das Google halt irgendwie die glänzender er sowas wie wir mit X.
Ja also oder anders gesagt ich finde so einfach sind die Sachen nicht
und ich habe so den Eindruck bei einem oberflächlichen Betrachtung dass es sich die EU ja auch ein bisschen leicht macht und dass das auch alles so ein bisschen
geiles haben wir mal was gefunden wo wir auf amerikanische Konzerne einschlagen können meine mit derselben Argumentationen könnte man ja Apple sozusagen auch alles verbieten,
so ihr erlaubt ja gar keine anderen Browser und er gibt ja alles nicht kostenlos weg damit andere Leute auch Telefone mit eurem Betriebssystem bauen können.
Kennwort kommt aber halt auf 80% Marktanteil in Europa,
in Celle Installationen und Google auf im W90 also die Suchmaschine Google 90% Marktanteil.
Das ist halt eine marktbeherrschende Stellung und wenn Apple in dir in den gleichen Schuhen stünde dann wären die wahrscheinlich auch dran aber solange du nicht in einer Merkvers Innenstellung bist.
Ja aber was aber was würdest du ihn dann sozusagen vorwerfen angenommen ist wenn alle nur noch iPhone 90% aller Telefone werden iPhone was müssen sich dann auf einmal ändern.
Na er würde nur Apple würde genau diesen Vorwurf nicht kriegen weil die Apple würde ja sagen die marktbeherrschende Stellung bei uns kann ja jeder die Default Suchmaschine werden es kauft nur Google halt immer,
die die Position also wer ein Browser herstellt.
Verkauft ja die voreingestellte Suchmaschine so ist der Firefox-Browser finanziert der ist primär durch Google finanziert weil Google dafür bezahlt die primäre Suchmaschine zu sein will jetzt und Wettbewerbshüter sein,
ein lieber Mozilla ihr verkauft es an andere auch ihre marktbeherrschende Stellung dann ist das in Ordnung könnte jemand anders auch.
Ja wir sind im Browser geht's umso.
Dafür hat ja Google jetzt hier primär in offen.
Also willst du die suchen Suchmaschine geht aber hier ging es ja jetzt nicht primär um die Suchmaschine oder.
Doch primär auch um die Suchmaschine und um an.
Und der App Store lädt aber beim AppStore ist es halt dann wieder so eine andere Sache ne.
Prima prima aber die sowas.
Ja gut aber du kannst dann weil dann ist natürlich das Problem da Apple sagt wer darf in den App Store rein und zu welchen Konditionen und so also schwierig zu entscheiden.
Hätte Apple einen einen Marktanteil von irgendwie was weiß ich über 90% wäre das auf jeden Fall so wie der App Store funktioniert
auf jeden Fall ein Fall für die marktwächter weil nämlich soweit ich das aus den Apple Programmierer Podcast höre er ja immer auch diese Regel hatte irgendwie keine Funktionalität
das Betriebssystem ist duplizieren oder gibt's das nicht mehr.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Regeln die auch am laufenden Meter angepasst werden
das mit dem Finger was jetzt mit duplizieren meinst dass es geht primär darum dass keine privaten nicht veröffentlichten Framework verwendet werden solche Sachen werden halt raus
aber ich denke dass größere Probleme sind so Sachen wie wenn du hier etwas verkaufst dann kriegen wir unseren share davon,
na diese 30% Regel für jegliche Dienstleistungen die darüber verkauft wird das natürlich so ein bisschen Aufhänger unter mit natürlich auch verbunden quasi die
Unmöglichkeit,
einen neuen bezahl Weg in irgendeiner Form zu etablieren anderes payment Modell etablieren und so und das ist natürlich auch ein generelles Problem,
und ich habe nur den Eindruck dass wir da auch alle noch gar keine richtigen Antworten zu haben also einfache feine gibt's nicht wie du es eben mit,
Google schon eingeleitet hast die ganzen Probleme die das macht so einen offenen Markt zu machen Apple verzichtet da von vorne rein drauf und die Vorteile sind ja sie haben,
also für Apple ist dass ich der Vater wir haben mehr Kontrolle die Kontrolle von Apple ist aber auch gut für die Anwender weil das heißt eben auch
mehr Kontrolle über Malware mehr Kontrolle über Privatsphäre und Datenschutz verletzende Maßnahmen und da haben sie ja dann eben auch.
Viele gute Schritte getan und eben auch viel erreicht und das ist halt ein Abwägen ne also dieses einfache Janni alles muss irgendwie offen und jeder überall passt halt auch teilweise gar nicht mehr in die Welt also,
sie gibt keine einfachen Antworten,
wir nehmen einfach mal nur zur Kenntnis dass die EU in der Lage ist die cathelco jetzt aber auch wirklich mal richtig zu schwingen und gucken mal,
was da in Zukunft noch so passiert.
Leider halt wie immer zu spät ne also in der Situation wo Google jetzt schon irgendwie seid
weiß nicht wie viel Jahren 90% Marktanteil bei den Suchmaschinen hat was ich noch niedrig geschätzt finde in der dass das Betriebssystem Android ist marktbeherrschend immobil,
Geräte bereits seit Ewigkeiten die kommen halt zu spät ja und dann Strafen sie da halt so ein Unternehmen ab jetzt 4,43 Milliarden klingt irgendwie irre die hä.
Als Maximalstrafe 10 % des weltweiten Jahresumsatzes nehmen können nimmt das heißt ja mir,
weniger als die Hälfte der Maximalstrafe vergeben also man könnte das auch so ein bisschen.
Halbherzig in NA google wird auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Euro haben um sich dagegen zu wehren
und ich weiß auch nicht inwiefern solche Entscheidung jetzt vielleicht auch einzubetten sind in das größere politische Geschehen sprich,
Strafzölle gegen bestimmte Industrien,
in in der Diskussion zwischen den USA und verschiedenen europäischen und asiatischen Nation das da jetzt plötzlich mal Google einen aufn Sack kriegt und so ne marktbeherrschende Stellung ja,
verwehren jetzt noch als Konkurrent da.
Ja ist alles schwierig.
Interessant wäre noch die Frage wo geht die Kohle hin interessantestes also dass die Mitgliedsbeiträge.
Zur Europäischen Union,
haben einen quasi einen Verteilungsschlüssel und das gilt natürlich auch für die Einnahmen aus diesen Strafen,
und weil Deutschland einer der wichtigsten Geldgeber innerhalb der EU ist würde Deutschland auch von dieser Strafe stärker profitieren in Deutschland würde das sowas wie 900000000 ausmachen das heißt MW,
fast ein Viertel von fast ein Viertel von diesem,
44 Milliarden wer würde dann in irgendeiner Form Deutschland in Form von Erleichterungen Zahlungen an die EU entgegenkommen.
Eine Entscheidung des Verfassungsgerichts.
Genau das ist ein Thema da da habe ich ja schon gedacht da gibt's wenig zu zu berichten eigentlich an dieser Stelle aber das ist ja ein Thema was die Gemüter erhitzt.
Das ist so.
GEZ.
Ist das ja früher jetzt ist das ja der Rundfunkbeitrag also dass sich die die deutsche Regierung deutsche Staat dazu entschieden hat den Leuten Geld abzunehmen,
um ein Rundfunk zu finanzieren also Lügenpresse halt so na und.
Hast du jetzt nichts gesagt.
Das ist ja die Stadt also die staatlich gleichgeschalteten Rundfunk Orkan und wird immer sein muss irgendeiner bezahlen das mit Geld nehmen die von uns aus unserer Tasche wo keiner hat gefragt ob ich damit machen will.
Moment ich muss mal hier kurz ich muss mal kurz den Linus wieder raussuchen irgendwie in diese neue jeder geht ja gar nicht.
So es gibt einen es gibt eine lange.
Ich richtige herum.
Es gibt eine lange Liste an Für und Wider für Diesel,
Überlegung ich glaube ich habe meine Position hier auch schon mal klar gemacht ich bin relativ froh dass wir so etwas haben.
Ich halte das so ein bisschen wie Helmut Schmidt so das mit dem Privatfernsehen war wirklich einfach echt gefährlich und,
gesehen dass jeder zu jeder Zeit wie schlimm das eigentlich ist aber sagen wir mal so eine eine staatlich finanzierte der.
Bestimmt bestimmt einen idealen verpflichtete Rundfunk Instanz,
ist sehr gut es ist wahrscheinlich auch gut dass es eine private Konkurrenz dazu gibt wenn es nämlich jemals die Situation kommen würde das nun der Staat sich der,
der ARD der ZDF und der regionalen Programme in irgendeiner Form bemächtigt und daraus irgendwie ein Fox-News macht dass wir dann auf,
was weiß ich,
ProSieben immer noch die Wahrheit erzählt bekommen würden sie die Frage ist die Ansagen jetzt dieser Fall ist schon eingetreten ist noch nicht eingetreten aber überhaupt das der,
der Staat nun hingeht und sagt wir wollen Geld haben und wir betreiben damit,
ARD und da kommt dann Musikantenstadl na dass das hat einige Leute über Jahrzehnte inzwischen halt erregt und die haben sich dagegen gewehrt und denn sie gucken ja gar kein Fernsehen,
oder.
Frankenradio haben gar kein Radio na das ist früher ging das ja noch da so früher konntest du wenn du gesagt hast ich habe kein Radio und kein Fernseher
dann muss dann sind ja auch noch kontrollieren gekommen ne wenn du Pech hattest kam dir vorbei und wenn du dann da gerade eben so unter der Dusche so I live in Austin Hessen dann war halt schlecht vor aber.
Du konntest früher sagen ich nutze das nicht.
Mit der Reform von paar Jahren mit der Rundfunkgebühr ist das nicht mehr der Fall du kannst also quasi einen Haushalt errichten in dem sich kein neuartiges Empfangsgerät also hier Wie heißt was heißt das hier.
Computer genau so kein neuartiges Empfangsgerät kein FM Radio kein AM Radio,
keine Röhrenfernseher gar nichts du hast nichts du hast ein Bücherregal so einer musst du trotzdem 17 € hast du nicht gesehen monatlich,
was jetzt auch nicht wenig Geld ist entrichten und wenn du dir jetzt einen zweiten derartigen Haushalt ein richtest,
auch wieder völlig wavy ne dann musstest du für den auch noch mal bitte.
Und da gab es eine Reihe an Verfassungsbeschwerden die sich gegen alles mögliche richteten also ich habe ich,
ich gucke das gar nicht ich habe das gar nicht ich habe einen zweiten Haushalt oder ich finde das auch ungerecht weil der Millionär muss genauso viel Rundfunkbeitrag zahlen Sie,
wieder die Hartz IV Empfängerin oder was ne und auch die,
also diese ganzen Gerechtigkeit fangen dann Alter ich auf die Fall das ist doch eigentlich eine Steuer und diese Steuer unterliegt ja hier nicht dem Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz und was es da nicht alles gab ist alles was Bundesverfassungsgericht gegangen.
Und Bundesverfassungsrichter gesagt du das könnte ja durchaus rummachen das einzige was nicht in Ordnung ist dass ihr für eine Zweitwohnung auch noch mal Gebühr Verlag.
Anderen Worten die die sich die Zweitwohnung leisten können kriegen jetzt hier die im Prinzip die Erleichterung ja wenn man jetzt aus einer Verteilungsgerechtigkeit schaut so dass es dann eben wirklich nur einmal.
Es gibt natürlich für Leute mit wenig Geld auch eine Befreiung vom Rundfunkbeitrag muss man dazu sagen.
Wie was wenig Geld ist entscheide immer noch ich.
Und der andere hat ja auch sechste geklagt und argumentiert warum zahlen wir denn jetzt hier für jedes Auto auch noch den Rundfunkbeitrag,
dem konnte sich das Bundesverfassungsgericht so nicht anschließen dieser Sichtweise und von daher haben wir eine Bestätigung des Status Quo abzüglich Zweitwohnung Kohle,
war dann sagen muss Zweitwohnung ja also.
Ich halte das auch für unsinnig also ich finde ganz ehrlich finde das schon.
Leute die woanders arbeiten deswegen eine zweite Wohnung haben mir zittere schon okay dass man das jetzt lässt dass es jetzt ein paar Millionäre gibt die drei Wohnungen haben und sich noch mal 32.
Die haben auch mehr inberlinwohnen hatte 77 Häuser beschlagnahmt also so ein Millionär hat man mehr.
Wann hat offene Hände in X Wohnung ja.
Also sein Verein bis kommt nicht darauf an ob in der Wohnung überhaupt ein Empfangsgerät bereitgehalten wird.
Unabhängig ob du überhaupt so ein Gerät besitzt können wir das nehmen maßgeblich ist das eine realistische Nutzungsmöglichkeit besteht nicht schon echt krass also und diesem Nutzungsmöglichkeit ist gegeben.
Weil den Beitragsschuldner durch das Beschaffen von sprechenden Empfangsgeräten ein Empfang im gesamten Bundesgebiet möglich ist,
also für Mobilfunknetz nicht da könntest Du nicht ganz klar sagen soll ever.
Exile all falls 82%.
Aber da halt FM wirklich also di.fm Abdeckung in Deutschland ist könnte daran könnten sich die Mobilfunknetze ein Beispiel nehmen.
Das ging komischerweise.
Und deswegen ist er so.
Ja ich finde das auch,
grundsätzlich okay da wird auch dieses auch wenn man das nicht empfängt oder nicht empfangen willst hat man trotzdem mit,
ist insofern in Ordnung als dass ich die eigentliche Wirkung dieses rundfunkbeitrags halt so sehe das,
eben diese Instanz existiert aufrechterhalten wird das ist einfach ein
weitgehend von Markt Zwergen Werbung und anderen Einflussnahmen entkoppelten redaktionellen journalistisches Betrieb gibt
wenn er sich halt auch nur in Anführungsstrichen auf Fernsehen und Radio primär erstreckt allerdings.
Erschrecken muss das Herdorf eingeschränkt also da hast du ja dann wieder um die Verlage die die Amok laufen.
Ist ja jetzt nicht so dass es kein tagesschau.de gibt also du du hast ja Textbeiträge auch im Netz.
Ja aber da sind HID also da musst du das ist das andere der andere politische kam die Verlage WR wehren sich mit Händen und Füßen dagegen und,
wird tagesschau.de wird immer wieder zurückgedrängt weil die Verlage sagen nee.
Aber reden wir darüber was was ich rede darüber was was finde ich angemessen und und wie würde ich das gerne sehen und in gewisser Hinsicht war eigentlich die Tatsache dass dieser dieser öffentliche Rundfunk eben auf Funk beschränkt war
eigentlich Quatsch natürlich war es gar nicht vorstellbar irgendwie eine bundesweite Zeitung zu machen nur
das ist jetzt nicht mehr so und meiner Meinung nach kann man nicht nur sagen wann wir Funken in Bild und Ton soll man. Natürlich auch in Text und im Internet ist das alles möglich,
wenn es nach mir geht sollte dieser Rundfunkbeitrag dazu verwendet werden dass eben die öffentlich-rechtlichen Anstalten sollen Ismus Anstalten bis jetzt meinen,
selbstverständlich vollumfänglich nach ihrer eigenen Maßgabe ohne irgendwelche Einschränkungen auch Text produzieren,
und scheiß auf Markt und so weiter die haben schon immer ihre Wege gefunden,
ja der Boulevard ist davon eigentlich sowieso nicht groß beeindruckt und dann ja muss halt Welt und Spiegel dementsprechend auch ein anderes Konzept in Gegensätzen um daneben da mitzuhalten
sie vollkommen in Ordnung es wird trotzdem noch geht.
Sonne wenn jetzt in die auf Nachrichten und so also wenn jetzt in ihr denkt natürlich ist MEWA die aldi aktuell Produktion also Tagesschau Tagesthemen.
Ein oder andere Talkshow vielleicht auch noch wenn es sein muss Wissenschaftsmagazine ne das ist eben wie das was wir anschauen,
da muss zumindest für diese Sendung gilt auch davon profitiere ich als Bürger der Bundesrepublik Deutschland auch wenn ich das nicht gucke weil wenn wir hier nur noch Fox & Friends hätten,
dann wer demnächst was weiß ich irgendwie Seehofer.
Oder oder du oder dieser Nazi aus bonnhagen ne keine Ahnung also irgendwie es ist sinnvoll sich da einen finanziellen Zwängen unabhängigen,
journalistischen Betrieb so wenn die dann aber natürlich hingehen und sagen jetzt machen wir hier noch mal wie heißt das Musikantenstadl oder sowas ne
klar dann dann wird argumentiert ja das ist aber das gucke ich ja jetzt gar nicht nichts zahle ich meinen Rundfunkbeitrag nur für Montag und das heißt auch nicht dass ich das alles großartig finde was in diesem,
auf diesen Kanälen kommt da kommt eben auch viel scheiße und das muss man irgendwie muss man ja irgendwie auch mit mit hin.
Ja aber dafür kommen da auch sehr viel
tolle Sachen die es halt auch in einem privaten Angebot gar nicht gibt da muss man nur mal Beate einschalten was da an Dokumentation und künstlerischen zu euch läuft das sind einfache wiederum auch Formate die so überhaupt
keine Chance hätten auf dem marktwirtschaftlichen base.
Jetzt wäre natürlich wird noch der andere Kritikpunkt kommen dass man sagt okay was die BBC macht mit einem Bruchteil dieser Summe an Geld ist eine sehr viel großartiger Geschichte.
Über den Wassers ich die die die Disziplin beim Geld ausgeben in diesen Institutionen was die aus Ihrem Geld machen.
Thema ist ein ganz anderes da gibt es auf jeden Fall Kritikpunkte wo irgendwie das Geld verballert wird und die Dinger eben wie Behörden laufen und mit im mit entsprechenden mit entsprechender Ineffizienz.
Ich finde auch die 17,50 € Finger einfach zu hoch also der Betrag.
Mehr 17-98 glaube.
50 in der Kategorie auf jeden Fall da ist sicherlich eine Menge von das allermeiste Geld fließt halt ein.
Ja also das ist einfach die die auf.
Das hast du sehr.
Ja ich kann dir jetzt keine genauen Zahlen sagen aber das ist so also was wird dich am Ende redaktionell quasi dort,
wird na also der Aufwand der da getrieben wird der ist schon extrem groß klar die gewisser Hinsicht muss auch ein großer Aufwand getrieben werden,
müssen auch teure Produktion möglich sein und muss noch Unterhaltungs Sachen möglich sein einfach weil man ja auch um Sonne,
Angebot auch eine gewisse Identität und Attraktivität erzeugen muss,
und dann sollen die Leute einfach ihren Scheiß Musikantenstadl gucken ist mir so egal weil davon geht die Welt auch nicht unter und wenn die sich dann wohl fühlen bei ARD und ZDF hat auch,
künstlerische breite ecentral muss er ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch seine Heimat bieten wir das jetzt nur so ein News Kanal wäre.
Bitte auch tagesschau24 und was also.
Ja die gibt's auch aber es ist nicht das einzige was sie machen vielleicht könnte man sich da auch noch ein bisschen rosa
ich bin voll dafür die Debatte zu führen über den Umfang was sagen wir mal jetzt gerade Nachrichten und Kern realistisch fremde Dinge betrifft mich voll dabei.
Höhe des Betrages K.
Finde aber eben auch Dokumentationen die es auch nicht im eigentlichen Sinne erstmal journalistisch sind auch genauso legitim
Nacktbilder einfach ne Bericht über die Tierwelt und die Arktis und Basiswissen und überhaupt lernen lernen unterstützende Maßnahmen das will ich da einfach sehen.
Sendung mit der Maus.
Sendung mit der Maus Kinderfilme ganz wichtig also Bob Kinder Kinderprogramm Kinderangebote.
Bei dir sonst nur die ganze Zeit ewig Kaugummi.
Wie und wie und das gut dass du das erwähnst hätte es fast vergessen ne mal ehrlich wie gut bitte ist das Kinderprogramm in den öffentlichen rechtlichen Rundfunk und dann schalt einmal rüber in irgendwas privates,
da wirst du doch bekloppt bei so und.
Denk an die Kinder.
Denk doch mal an dich noch mal an.
Wenn ihr das nicht kennt guckt euch mal wissenmachtah an.
Achso okay ich dachte irgendwie in die nein hier Quarks und Co Quarks und Caspers Sendung mit der Maus Kopf weil ich weiß habe Kopfhörer noch gibt im Moment sagt er mir wie ein.
Kika ist überhaupt ein Quell der Freude sicherlich da gibt's dann auch hier da ein bisschen zu viel Prinzessinnen und Superheld aber im Großen und Ganzen wirklich wirklich gute Sachen Logo Nachrichten für Kinder.
Der ist schon ganz in Ohren.
Genau da wo da wo dann immer die komplizierten Themen aufgedröselt werden für die Kinder und im Detail erklärt wird also wie ein Pott.
Erinnere mich daran got Amazon Interview mit dir würde ich will meine eigene ID sein.
Das ist ja also mein lieblings.
Habt ihr schon euren Rundfunkbeitrag einen kleinen Tipp.
Die 1001 Daueraufträge Challenge läuft noch.
Dann kriegst du ein Eis Paket über den Kopf.
Stadt Marl Schmitz imhorst.
Es gibt noch eine Verfassungsbeschwerde und zwar die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte muss ich ja wirklich sagen meine Güte sind die fleißig ne also ist wirklich eine feine Angelegenheit ist angetreten.
Und ich weiß gar nicht mit wie vielen Verfassungsbeschwerden die irgendwie im Jahr um sich werfen aber ich würde jetzt schätzen dass es im Monat eine,
so jetzt im Schnitt es können auch fehlt vielleicht eine nur eine alle zwei Monate manchmal kommen paar mehr paar weniger und diesmal richten sie sich gegen,
ein Thema was ich auch sehr wichtig fand letztes Jahr wenn ich mich nicht täusche gab es die Novelle des.
E-id Gesetzes quasi oder des Pass und ausweisgesetz ist quasi wo gesagt wurde.
Jetzt gibt es alles Neue Personalausweis und Passgesetz so und jetzt müsst ihr das mit dem biometriedaten machen ihr müsst die abgeben.
Und die kommen in komm dann auf die Pässe und auf die.
Hör auf die Personalausweise und in dem rutschen wir gleich eine gleichzeitig einfach nur mal eingeführt automatischen Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Nicht nur in den Meldeämter sondern jetzt an zentraler Stelle für.
Polizei von Bund und Ländern alle Geheimdienste Zoll Steuerfahndung.
Verfassungsschutz habe ich gesagt nein alle Geheimdienste alle dürfen da drauf.
Und können quasi dann dieses biometrische Bild was bei der Erstellung des Dokumentes abgegeben wurde zugreifen,
so und dieser Zugriff wird in keiner vom kontrolliert der unterliegt auch keinen Beschränkungen da steht jetzt nicht darfst du wenn Verdacht besteht auf
schwere Verbrechen nach Kategorie A B oder C oder wird protokolliert und wenn du den Zugriff gemacht hast musst die Zielpersonen spätestens nach Ende des Ermittlungsverfahren darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden sondern
gar nichts,
ist einfach so dürfen die drauf zugreifen an zentraler Stelle.
Entschieden in einer Zeit wo wir am Südkreuz in Berlin damals noch unter Thomas de Maiziere diese Testfahrten zur Gesichtserkennung Systeme also wo Menschen im.
Öffentlichen Raum erkannt werden sollen,
das ist echt ein hartes Stück wenn du dir überlegst wie diese Gesicht erkennungs Algorithmen in letzter Zeit zu nehmen dass wir in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland dann kannst jetzt überlegen
eine erwachsene Person kann da sind die Pässe glaube ich maximal zehn Jahre gültig.
Personalausweise glaube ich auch oder ich weiß keinen Pass zehn Jahre gültiges aber im Personalausweis ist doch ich maximal zehn Jahre gültig.
Achso ja genau ein Beruf? Wie ist das wie lange ist ein deutscher Pass gültig.
Also Podcast habe ich 13 Jahre.
Ich meine auch also meiner ist noch ein paar.
Also die Pritsche Reisepass Kind 10 Jahre ist.
Die Pritsche Reisepass Kind 10 Jahre.
So das heißt wenn jetzt diese wenn das Paar Personalausweisen auffe ist und die Leute ihrer Verpflichtungen nachkommen einen gültigen Personalausweis vorzuhalten dann hast du nach 10 Jahren spätestens,
eine komplette vollständige Biometrie biometrische Datenbank deiner.
Mitarbeiter in der BRD GmbH weil ihr alle Personalausweis bekommen.
Bitte bitte ich weiß dass du das lustig findest aber sie aber das weiß ich auch dass ihr olitec hier ausreichend eingeklammert ist nein würde ich nicht daß die BRD eine GmbH ist.
Ich war sehr verwundert dass hier xavier naidoo na der hat ja geklagt weil man ihn nicht antisemite nennen sollten hat auch gewonnen aber ich frage mich warum klagt er überhaupt vor diesen extra legalen Gerichten ja.
Sieht doch gar nicht zuständig für ihn als Reichsbürger.
Besatzer macht hier also,
du hast dann eben nachts spätestens nach 10 Jahren eine vollständige biometrische Datenbank,
der Bewohner des Landes in der Zeit wo die jung sind und sich die noch stark ändern die biometrischen Merkmale,
halten die Pässe idd Personalausweis auch nicht solange du musst ja Küsse nur für fünf Jahre oder so,
und das ist natürlich sehr schlecht wenn du gleichzeitig diese ganzen Gesichtserkennung Algorithmen machst weil dann hast du in summer gefühlten 10-15 Jahren tatsächlich die Grundlage dafür,
eine biometrische voll Erkennung öffentlichen Raum durchzuführen.
So wie das jetzt in China auch umgesetzt wird.
Dagegen.
Chucky GFF und sagt na ja okay also alles schlecht und insbesondere wenigstens Vorschriften für die Polizei ein Geheimnis so toll und sonstigen fahren Umständen das man sagt unter welchen Voraussetzungen der Zugriff stattfindet wie die,
Weiterverwendung geregelt ist also ja du also im Moment ist wenn du möchtest kannst du zugreifen nimm,
GFF sagt natürlich so erstens unter welchen Bedingungen darfst du zu welchem Zweck was machst du mit diesen Daten was darfst du mit den Daten machen was hast du nicht mit den Daten machen und so weiter.
Und dafür hat die GFF jetzt eben eine Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht Beschwerdeführer sind unter anderem auch Markus Beckedahl und andre Meister von netzpolitik.org und jetzt wollen wir schauen wie das,
wie das ausgeht hoffen natürlich dass das eine Einschränkung gibt dieser dann doch sehr skurrilen praktisch Praxis.
Und damit werden wir.
Bei den Termin.
Wären wieder einige Empfehlungen von euch bekommen insbesonder diesmal am 14. August richtet der chaospott eine cryptoparty aus 19 Uhr.
Und Link findet ihr in den Shownotes 15 August in Essen in der sibyllastraße 9,
45136 Essen Süd,
Service ist hilfreich wird aber nicht vorausgesetzt die Veranstaltung wendet sich an Nutzerinnen und Nutzer die sich mit dem Thema Passwörter bisher wenig oder nie beschäftigt haben wer sich für diese Thematik interessiert ist herzlich eingeladen in ca 2 Stunden,
zu lernen wie man sichere Passwörter verwendet die manivet verschlüsselt und was ich alles Teilnahme kostenlos und man kann sich natürlich vorstellen wenn das vom chaospott ist,
das da natürlich auch ein leichter Bezug steht zudem was wir kürzlich aus der chaospott Stadt Dortmund berichtet haben.
Genau in Bayern gibt's ja auch entsprechende Probleme da.
Burg am Wochenende zurück.
In Augsburg und genau stimmt da gibt's vom 28 bis 29 September,
die hackerkiste 2018 was ist.
Hast du verstanden warum die hackerkiste heißt die Augsburger hackerkiste.
Achso die Augsburger hackerkiste ich verstehe okay.
Ja ja ja da sind wir wieder bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Kinderprogramm.
Entschuldigung dass die Anspielung habe ich jetzt in diesem Moment gerade nicht gesehen aber
gut besser nicht verstanden hat das ist hier quasi das Hacker äquivalent zu Puppenkiste auf jeden Fall dabei soll es sich handeln um eine Konferenz ein Barcamp,
und einen Heckeshorn da wird also gehackt,
bis zum 5. August 2018 könnt ihr auch noch Torx und andere Dinge einreichen,
Parkett Sessions oder eben auch für den Hecke Sorten und das scheint mir alles sehr flexibel gehalten zu sein 2018 Punta kkiste.de,
bringt dich ans Ziel.
War geil so müssen jetzt immer noch mit den Termin dass die Melodie genau dann endet wenn wir fertig sind.
Tut er das nicht hübscher stimmt.
Der Wahnsinn ab jetzt immer nur noch zwei Termine.
Ja ja.
So kommen wir hier langsam zum Ende einer Sendung wir wissen nicht ob wir die noch hochgeladen bekommen hier ne.
Also nicht in der Dreiviertelstunde ist noch nicht mal fertig geschnitten und dann hätte ich ja noch.
Und und dann noch so über Nacht können wir mal gucken wie viel dieser Sendung wir holen wenn die zwischendrin abbricht dann hast du dich noch nicht ganz hochgeladen.
Und dann ich danke auf jeden Fall am Ende der Sendung dem Robert den Sebastian aus Dubai.
Ja den Christian dem Maximilian dem Lars und dem Stefan,
herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung freundliche Grüße und so weiter und Tim du wolltest doch noch mal hier die Märchen von Tausend und einem Metaebene Dauerauftrag erwähnen.
Bitte sieht jetzt mal schnell tschüss.
Ja aber nur kurz also ich habe sie jetzt auch erst nachdem ihr angehört die Freakshow.
Ja ich habe ein bisschen noch mal die die Stelle verlinken das Kapitel falls ihr Freakshow T-Shirt das kann ja sein,
nachgezählt und so wie viele Leute eigentlich tatsächlich eine regelmäßigen Beitrag leisten einen Rundfunkbeitrag sozusagen ja,
und es ein bisschen mal in Verhältnis gesetzt zu was ich so annehmen kann was so eine Stamm Hörerschaft ausmacht ungefähr das sind natürlich alles sehr schwierig zu greifende,
zahlen hat das dann wiederum in Relation gesetzt zu,
dieser Behauptung diesem Raum steht das irgendwie eine gute Band von 5% ihrer Fans eigentlich überleben müsste so,
unten ja,
dann gabs da so ein kleines Missverhältnis und dann habe ich mir gedacht dann müsste man vielleicht mal so dass man diese Zahl der der Daueraufträge auf das entsprechende Niveau gehoben bekommen was in dem Fall der einfache Rechnung ist,
gehst jetzt auch wie knapp 500 das mal auf 1000 oder 1001 kommen und dann funktioniert,
auch alles schon wieder sehr viel besser weil es mir dann einfach auch mehr möglich bin jetzt auch sehr.
Arme die ganzen Format mit meiner das ein bisschen begleitet weil ich habe viele Formate gestarten passend zum bisschen ins Hintertreffen geraten so lautsprecher das hat auch viele Gründe weil teilweise auch einfach vieles von den Zielen die ich damit hatten wir auch erreicht,
sind so andere regelmäßige Sachen wie News of the World das Ding dann einfach auch zeitlich alles nicht mehr war da halt einfach mal so Experimente die man paar Jahre gemacht hat
jetzt hat sich das an wie ganz gut eingedampft aber ich gerade,
geradezu Logbuch Netzpolitik ist etwas passt doch recht viel Zeit einem so ne also der der Tag ist ja damit eigentlich immer mehr oder weniger komplett beschäftigt nicht weil man jetzt unbedingt immer
8 oder 10 Stunden dran sitzt das vielleicht nicht manchmal auch aber auch weil,
man man kann danach altern auch einfach gar nichts anderes mehr machen ist und wo musst du irgendwie auch die Kotze.
Sofort zum Frust.
Ja heute haben wir das auch gesehen also wie viel Stunden Anlauf haben wir gebraucht bis von Dirk lass mal gleich mal aufnimmt das ist dann wirklich losging irgendwie.
12 in dem Fall tatsächlich 12.
So ist es na ja also wer sich da noch mit einklinken möchte das ist natürlich
gern gesehen aber grundsätzlich ist es mir auch immer wichtig zu betonen dass ich keine Lust habe
das hier immer wieder zu wiederholen und auf Leute einzureden und irgendwelche dauerhaften
blo blo blo blo und Bedingungen und Aufforderungen
Namenslisten und all das was an anderen Stellen so gepflegt wird es,
weiß ich nicht wissen okay wenn ihr das irgendwie so hört es ist okay wenn ihr irgendwie auch nicht Beitrag weil es nicht nicht nicht nicht könnt oder aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht wollt.
Wenn das irgendjemand also die die Regel ist ja ganz einfach wenn wenn ihr.
Sagt das ist ein Angebot was für mich irgendwie attraktiv ist aus dem ich einen Nutzen ziehe.
Dann könnt ihr euch darüber Gedanken machen ob ihr einen Beitrag zum Fortbestand des Angebots leisten möchtet wenn ihr den finanziellen Beitrag nicht leisten könnt dann lasst es bitte sein dann studiert zu Ende werdet gute Menschen.
Oder reich und wenn ihr reich werdet dann.
Betten und wenn nicht wenn die einfach nur gute Menschen hat ist auch gut ja wenn wir unseren Beitrag dazu.
Bundeswehr darf ich dann auch was von.
Genau.
Das ist das ist ja dann auch.
Und wer die ansonsten wenn man sich weil ich dass man schön Kaffee Geld ausgibt dann kann man sich auch überlegen ob man vielleicht im Monat lebt im und Kaffee ausgibt bei so viel Kaffee trinkt ja gar nicht.
Gerade angemacht.
Ja der war auch wichtig vor der Sendung sehr wichtig gut genug genervt Leute vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und weitererzählen und Kunde verbreiten.
Kunde verbreiten das ist eigentlich ich freue mich auf jeden mehr über und Zählung Weiterempfehlung ja sagst du Wachs und Wachs.
Wird es ist es stimmt aber auch so ich meine diese,
wird deine Glücklichkeit Faktor der ist auch steigt auch enorm durch das man sieht dass Leute das als relevant oder hilfreich ansehen und es dann eben auch aktiv weitertragen.
Also ich kann ganz ehrlich wie lange war was jetzt im bis 56 Jahre oder so ich hätte dass ich würde das nicht machen wenn das nicht so viele Leute reichen würde also dass das ist der Haupt Motivator.
Genau das denke ich auch.
Mehr Leute mehr Motivation mehr schlechte Nachrichten aus dem Internet für euch.
Mit euch überlegen.
Ja genau ansonsten bleibt ja erstmal alles gleich wir berichten weiter.
Kein Empfang ey.
Wir bereiten euch den Weltuntergang schön auf.
Mit einem Lächeln dann mit einem Lächeln in die Apokalypse in diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch ein sonniges Sommerwochenende oder wann auch immer ihr das hört.
Winden spielt beim Untergang der Beloch bunet wird gespielt noch die Band noch ein lustiges Lied wieder ciao ciao.